foreign
[Music]
good morning everybody thanks for taking
time to come to this session I see a lot
of familiar faces so that's great uh
good to see that there's a lot of
interest in this Mainframe modernization
um
we'll talk about Santander's journey to
moving Mainframe workloads to Cloud
but before that let me just briefly
introduce you to the other two speakers
with me first is Alejandro from
Santander he is the director of the
gravity project in Santander and he's
part of the CIO team and he'll be
talking to us today about you know their
experience and journey to actually
migrating Mainframe workflows to gcp
along with them is Brian Lee who is the
Chief Architect for dual run within
Google
and myself rajeshram chandran I lead the
Mainframe modernization practice
globally in Google right
so for as far as an agenda is concerned
um I have three topics there
initially I want to talk about the
Mainframe modernization approach from a
Google point of view what we think about
it how we approach it what we've heard
from customers and how we want to
how we tell customers to approach their
problems second is I'll double click a
little bit under Google Solutions I know
the 45 minutes is not enough time to
actually do justice to all the topics
here so we'll be glad to have some
follow-up sessions with you guys to
answer any more questions
third Santander will talk about their
Journey so that will be the third
session that will be there and then
we'll have about 10 minutes for Q a and
again
since there's a lot of people here you
know there's more questions we can
always have a follow-up session with you
guys
so Mainframe modernization from a Google
point of view right
so I don't know how many of you have
actually stuck in this island that we
see right
from a Mainframe point of view a lot of
customers have been building this it's a
great platform by the way right I mean
nothing wrong about the platform it's a
phenomenal platform it's run score
businesses for a lot of customers
and you know I've worked on the platform
in the past and I understand the value
of the platform but
modern days people are looking to see
how to improve efficiency increase
productivity create value
Drive Innovation reduce cost
while they want to do this the
challenges that customers have right is
I mean pretty sure a lot of you can
relate to these challenges right
Talent drain cost
you know shrinking talent pool
but while you have all of these
challenges customers also want to
migrate or modernize
pretty quickly off the Mainframe right
they don't want to take 10 years 15
years to migrate what they've built over
50 years right so they want to do that
much faster and of course they want to
do minimal risk
they want to be cost effective
and then on top of it
they want the same qualities of service
that the Mainframe is famous for right
that's very important I just want to
stress on one thing about gcp
while Mainframe has extraordinary
qualities of service gcp also has the
same similar qualities of servers right
just like how if you run a program on
the main Mainframe you inherit all the
capabilities of the Mainframe from a
high availability point of view
from our security point of view all of
that you get the same qualities of
service on gcp just by putting some
workload on gcp you inherit a lot of
infrastructure capabilities that Google
has built so that's a very important
point that I wanted to stress on
now how do we approach this problem for
customers
right
to be honest there's no one single
solution or a silver bullet for a lot of
customers right it's a modernization
journey that we talk about
so we always start from the first thing
that a lot of customers that we talk to
is about augmenting the Mainframe and I
think a lot of you are already doing
that from a fact of API enablement of
the Mainframe that's always been done so
that's one thing that we encourage
customers to continue to do that where
it's appropriate
the bigger thing that we're talking
about is
moving data or copying data from
Mainframe into gcp there's a lot of
benefits for that because once you move
the data or copy the data over to Cloud
now you can actually build lot more
Analytics
a lot more
applications Cloud native applications
on gcp right it's easier to access the
data that's in files vsam files and
things like that which are very
proprietary to the Mainframe right so
you get rid of all of that with this but
you can still keep your Mainframe
running in the meantime yeah your core
system of record is still there right
but this enables you to react faster to
the time to the business
give you new value you know new things
to the business
the second thing and we have a solution
for that which is called the Mainframe
connector right which is actually an
open source solution and I'll double
click into that in the next few slides
the next thing is there are some
customers who come to us and say Hey I
want to quickly get out of my data
center
right they have a data center exit
strategy and they want to be host their
infrastructure by Google right so with
that with respect to that
we have a solution called ip4g it's IBM
power for Google which is actually aimed
at AIX and as boundary workloads
while for the Mainframe we don't have an
official offering yet we are working
with Partners you know a lot of Partners
here like Kindle and DXE and web Pro and
others to actually help host these
workloads in data centers close to
Google Cloud
right and that will help customers exit
the data center
the next one is a re-platform solution
a lot of customers come to us and say
hey I'm pretty happy with it being in
Cobalt but the cost Factor
is pretty huge
for me I'm playing IBM a lot of money
I'm paying the isvs a lot of money so
can you help me stay on Cobalt can you
help me move to Cloud as the first step
in the modernization journey right with
respect to that we have a re-platforming
solution
which is called dual run and I'll click
go into it in a little bit detail and
that helps you accelerate the journey to
re-platforming okay typically I don't
want to steal Brian and you know Santa
and this is thunder so I'll let them
describe that solution and actually how
it actually works
with respect to that
then the next one is refactor we have
Google
solution which is G4 which is code
conversion so there are a lot of
customers who come to us and say hey I
don't want to be in Cobalt anymore I
have no Talent
I'm struggling to react to business very
quickly right so can I move to Java
quickly but I have a million lines of
code or 10 million lines of code if I go
down the rewrite path it's going to take
me a long time right and so we have a
solution which is called G4 which we
kind of acquired three years ago from
Cornerstone and we've actually it
actually takes
the code converts into Java we can run
in containers now what it buys you is
you're on on gcp in a cloud native
environment modern tooling access to
more skills the other important thing is
you know a lot of Enterprises 70 80
percent of the code is not maintained on
a regular basis
right you know on in the Mainframe only
20 30 percent is maintained what this
allows you is to get quickly off the
platform
and then you can focus on the 20 30
percent and do a rewrite
by the way I don't know how many of you
were
and attended the key developer Keynote
all right not many okay I don't know
initially when I joined Google I was
always thinking about you know Mainframe
and Google in the same sentence
I was not sure whether they'll ever be
there but then I heard the roots
actually making a hip-hop thing about
Mainframe so I was like okay we are cool
right now right so that was actually a
big
surprise for me to say okay even the
roots know about Mainframe right now
lastly we are you know a lot of
customers and I've talked to a few of
them even in this conference they
actually want to reimagine and change
their business processes and actually
bought undergo digital transformation
Google helps with respect to that right
with respect to rewriting and in both
these Solutions one important aspect
that you see there is
there's this gen AI piece that was added
right it was not there before to be
honest right but as the buzzword and
everybody is very interested in gen AI
right now we've started exploring that
right now and we will actually have
something out pretty soon that you can
share
why we have all of our Solutions we also
have partner Solutions along the way
now I'm just going to go quickly through
some case studies here
we've had some customers that we have
actually had success with
uh bovista is a public customer
reference Eric is a public customer
reference where we actually
got them off the got Mainframe workload
running on gcp using different solutions
we also have a data first solution with
one of the largest retailers in the
world in fact the Mainframe connector
was built there and actually
open sourced after that and then of
course we just recently did a refactor
with G4 for a large global bank from an
as200 platform and got it out on Google
Cloud
now from Google Solutions point of view
this is the augment solution that we're
talking about where we tell customers as
a strategy please copy your data onto
gcp because
it helps you build lot more new
applications on gcp much faster Cloud
native and all of this and also the rate
at which innovation happens on the cloud
is much faster than what you can get
on-prem so you can have vendors who give
you analytic Solutions but the rate at
which the Innovation happens on cloud is
much faster so this is actually
something that's very important that you
can take a look at we have a variety of
partner Solutions as well that we
actually recommend working with to help
you move in case you need CDC
next
this is just a detailed description of
what the solution is all about the
Mainframe connector actually helps you
migrate data as long as you can get the
data into a flat file with a Cobalt copy
book we can actually help you migrate in
a batch oriented way to gcp into
bigquery
right so this is a pretty standard
simple solution
you know it'll take you one month to
actually get this up and running and
you're done right so it's pretty
repetitive in case you need CDC then you
start looking at partner Solutions
talking about G4 I just want to put one
slide about G4 our approach is code
conversion and our Target is kubernetes
on the left side you see all the
languages the things that we currently
support as a tool
on the right side is the target platform
that we aim for right it's spring boot
angular containerized
Java batch running in kubernetes
that's our Target platform
so now
kubernetes
and the reason we didn't go to Cloud run
right now is some customers don't want
Cloud run because it's actually running
outside of their control in a tenant in
gcp so that's one of the reasons why we
chose kubernetes
but it very well could run on cloud run
there's nothing stopping there
now Brian over to you for dual run
thank you
this tour one so there are many
challenges and opportunities in
monolizing your legacy applications so
you have a Mainframe on the left and you
have a customers and other
organizations try to use your Mainframe
trusted the Mainframe and also Mainframe
send out some outputs right with the
solid line it works it mitsubishin is
but when it comes down to the the
modernizing the application especially
in the Mainframe modernization there are
two challenges right one of the many
challenges I would say is testability
whether it can be tested and also
whether it can be validated functionally
and non-functionally this is trusted
platform right you want to have a
ability to test it in real
environment
alongside with the production Mainframe
and then you want to be able to see the
behavior of the new system functionally
non-functionally along with in parallel
with Mainframe right so there are two
types of workload and you will have to
migrate the application first
so we will have application on gcp
assisted with our AMS
we have a
automation suite for you to migrate and
assisting in migrating to your existing
application assets to gcp when that's
done there are two types of workload
first one would be typical batch where
batch job schedule will handle all the
schedules and everything you will have a
similar or the same scheduler on gcp so
you will be able to run it on gcp but
will give you an ability to compare the
outputs and set up to your key
performance metrics indicators that you
can keep track of in seeing it through
the monitoring capability right then
there will be your online
you have interactive customers coming in
our launcher will
taken care of sending out the same
transaction into your Mainframe with the
solid line to gcp the dotted line
meaning this our gcp system will be
running in alongside with the Mainframe
but it will compare the output for you
so that you will be able to see the
order online behaviors including
functional non-functional Behavior
through a single pane of glass so so
that you'll be able to see it through
the monitoring so that you'll be able to
see the all the workload and behavior
in a single pane of glass almost real
time right
so then
we have another last concept is you're
running two systems independently there
may be some discrepancies not coming
from the defect
but sometimes time differences a little
bit of you know dispatching issues and
such so we'll have a little bit of
discrepancies but you will have to use
the Mainframe as a system of record so
that we will be able to reconcile little
differences to the secondary which is on
gcp so the the comparison everything
will keep going on without incurring any
too much discrepancies that's the basic
concept the last one is the message
coming out or buys coming out from two
systems out to the world we will also be
able to compare it and set up kpis so
that you will be able to keep monitoring
it so that's the basic concept then when
it comes down to how we can be done
smooth transition to the gcp right the
first one is as it is you have a
Mainframe trusted Mainframe serving the
public and business then we will be
engaging to a run the same way I just
presented it but you see this solid
lines every interaction from in and out
from the Mainframe will be receiving by
the outside customers so there will be
no impact but your new modernized system
will be running concurrently during the
comparison until you fine tune it you
correct any issues coming up
then the moment where you are confident
in
switching over to the new system that's
the third phase where the gcp will be
serving the public but your Mainframe
will be sitting behind the scene in case
just in case but we won't recommend this
phase to be too long but you will have a
freedom of going back if in case then
everything works fine then you will
decommission that you will run then your
gcp will be serving by your business
that's the brief introduction and let me
introduce Alejandro for his experience
Ryan
okay so first a little bit of context
here in Santander we operate in 10 main
geographies we have two core banking
Solutions one for Europe one and North
America and another one for South
America
and even though these platforms were
resilient they were stable they were
performant that we were facing some some
challenges challenges because these
platforms have been built 20 plus years
ago so we were facing challenges around
time to Market about efficiency and
that's why back in time a few years ago
we started the digital transformation of
our power banking Solutions we wanted to
move from analytic Mainframe based
heavily batched platforms into a new
digital
cloud-based RP event driven platform
there were similar goals that we wanted
to achieve with this transformation one
of them was cost reaction of usually we
wanted to adopt a new Cloud base if cost
a piece in platform we want to attain
sustainability we are saying that the
increasing transactional volumes the
year and year so that the flexibility
that a cloud-based platform would give
us would help us in managing this this
additional volumes while maintaining the
highest standards in terms of resilience
see availability and security
that one as I was mentioning before the
time to Market we were having some
challenges in keeping up pace with the
change in our backend systems compared
to what we do in our front-end systems
therefore by the adoption of a New Alm
stack we were planning to reduce the
time that we required for developing new
products and services and to reduce the
time for getting that into the market
real time as I was mentioning these
platforms were built 20 plus years ago
they were built under the paradigms of
that point in time heavily batched many
of the important things were happening
overnight so we are
kind of evolving this uh these
environments building event driven
platforms so that we move into a more
real-time for banking Solutions
app base some of the challenges that we
were facing as well is was that it was
difficult to interact with the
applications that we have in the
Mainframe there was complexity there so
in order to abstract that complexity for
the front-end developers we were setting
up an IP world that would provide and
expose the products and services that we
have in our core banking Solutions in
any standard way which at the same time
will also be a helpful in sense of
reusability so that we can build ones
and we can reuse that that new
application across the different
entities within the group
and then lastly data driven right
um access to data in the membrane was
the kind of cumbersome sometimes so with
this movement what we want to do is to
facilitate the access to that uh to that
data in order to be able to build a
business intelligent and so on so one of
the key elements in order to achieve how
this goes was first one uh moving into a
modern cloud-based platform
it was a key enabler for all the
different things that we are doing in
order to evolve our core packing
Solutions
first thing we do we did back in time
was to okay let's go to the market let's
see which
Native or banking Solutions do we have
there that we got news out of the box
however we didn't find any that would
fit all the requirements so the decision
was taken to less stretchable this core
banking platforms in-house
Second Challenge that we were facing was
we took that decision is okay how do we
do that how do we convince our estate
holders internal Regulators that the new
platform would be up to standards that
the new platform will be free for
purpose and this is when it came or we
came up with the Dual run solution
what is dual run Brian has already
explained it but basically what we
wanted to do is that we wanted to test
the new Cloud environment with real
production data real production volumes
and conditions Prior to setting up this
new environment as the primary one for
doing so we develop a set of tools that
would allow us to set up the new
platform in cloud and run it in parallel
with the Mainframe with the Mainframe
environment for that as Brian has been
explaining we developed a set of tools
that would allow us first to automate
the compression of the code that we run
in the Mainframe so that it could be
running the new runtime in Cloud second
is the the different tools that we use
to capture all incoming traffic that we
have in our mainframes to analyze it to
the new environment
and then a set of dashboards that would
pick up the outcomes from the Mainframe
from the new cloud-based environment and
compare the outputs and show them to to
our team so that we could certify both
phonetical and functional perspective
that the behavior of the new environment
was similar to the one that we had in
the Mainframe for one we also had a set
of tools that would allow us during the
stabilization periods of the Dual run to
keep on the data in the briefing and the
data in the cloud environment in sync
and lastly a set of tools that allow us
to make sure that we do not have
duplicated outputs so that only the
primary environment is the one that is
engaging with the with the outside wall
of the Mainframe
and what we were trying to achieve with
this solution first is to accelerate the
transition to Cloud facilitate this
transition to Cloud
as I was saying before this core packing
Solutions have been built 20 plus years
ago so using a traditional approach for
testing the new environment would be
really really difficult
that amount of unitary test cases would
imply a lot of effort across the
organization so that by doing this dual
run it allows us to simplify that
approach and as well make sure that we
can test 100 the new environment
second thing
is reducing the transition risks that's
risk management is really key in this
kind of projects so therefore by running
both environments in parallel we have
the opportunity to fall back to the
Mainframe at the beginning of the of the
transition in case anything goes wrong
and lastly another very important thing
that we wanted to achieve here is now to
minimal this reaction to business so as
we're gonna need to engage the
international teams across all the
organization for that unitary test
development and execution
um we would minimize the impact that we
have on our
book of work as well we we set up
mechanisms that allow us to deploy the
the new developments into the Mainframe
and deploy them as well in the new
cloud-based environment so that we keep
them in sync during the advanced period
so that the book of work the the
developments the evolution that is
taking place elsewhere in the
organization can continue without
disruption while we are doing this dual
run in the move to the cloud
now
um we are getting into what we are doing
with gcp the Escapade project what we
are doing is our core packing or
back-end solution that we use for scav
which is our Santander corporate
Investment Bank division we are moving
that backend to Google Cloud
from a functional perspective what do we
have in this environment is the
accounting payments we have applications
related to the market and treasury
represents of our Corporation Investment
Banking division along with several
extrateral systems about customer
database and product database
here we have a few figures that provide
some insight in terms of the size of the
environment that we're talking about we
have around 20 000 core programs 2 900
different six transactions
uh we're running on the daily basis
around 7600 jcls in our batch executions
there are more than a thousand files
being transferred outside after that
batch execution there are more around
5500 different DPT tables and in terms
of volumes what we have in this
environment is plus one million fixed
and assessions a day more than 2 million
accounting operations per day as well in
terms of transactions online
transactions we have peaks of around 150
transactions per second
and now moving into how has been our
journey we started January this year by
deploying The Landing zones and the
environments and TCP that we will be
using for running these applications at
Google Cloud
it was the first time that we were doing
sachana scale project at the Google
Cloud so that the support that we
receive from from your teams were very
helpful at that point in time
uh once we have set up the new
environment.cloud we migrated data
software and by April approximately we
were already doing the Dual running
pre-production following that dual
running pre-production we move into the
production environments production
environments were ready around June we
started to our running production around
early July
and now next steps we are planning to do
the final certification during the
September month and with the the target
of achieving or setting the new Cloud
environment as the primary one by
October
key figures here we did achieve around
99 automation transformation of the
software that we had in Mainframe on the
adaptation for the new Cloud runtime
environment we respected in 30 plus or
savings with this new environment and in
terms of the timeline we are we
expecting to to complete it within 10
months
lastly why Google Cloud well there were
many different reasons why we choose
Google I mean technical capabilities or
gcp where exactly what we were looking
for in terms of security resiliency
availability our Engineers love working
with gcp support I was mentioning it
before the support that we have received
from the Google Professional Services in
terms of Designing these new
environments have been very good across
all this journey
um Innovation I mean Google innovation
track is amazing so that it was the
right partner for further evolving this
dual run solution and bringing it to the
market and lastly we also wanted to
leverage on the new DCP
um region that was set up in in Madrid
apart from this there were other things
that we took into consideration around
the data and AI capabilities that Google
cloud has and which will definitely help
us in further evolving further I will
win our Platforms in the future
second time
oh sure I mean
we have already completed the the
project that we did in the UK corporate
bank that was put into production in
September last year then we also did a
programming in consumer Chile
and definitely what we are seeing is
that once the solution was matured
because we did the first the first
project we are still developed
developing the solution but now that it
has been developed it has been tested
there is a a
noticeable reduction in the time that
we're required since we start the or we
since we deployed a new environment at
Cloud I think and we started our run and
we go through the cycle you know the the
methodology that we are following we set
up the new environment that cloud we do
first the technical dual run technical
meaning that we are at that point in
time looking into making sure that we
have a complete to our run the technical
stabilization of the environment that
from a technical perspective the figures
and the the times that we have in this
environment are correct and then we move
into the certification or functional
dual run in which we involve the
business we involve the operations teams
in order to provide them with the
evidences that we get from the
dashboards that provide then evidence
that the new environment is
behaving effectively the same way that
it was doing in the Mainframe and the
time that we're required to go through
this process if it's been decreasing
once the the the solution has been
matured and that and once we have
completed it in previous countries
right